welcome to our unbiased blind camera  comparison with the brand new s22 ultra  against the iphone 13 pro max both of  these are 4k samsung made a big deal  about their nighttime videography  knightography they labeled it so let's  take a look  oh my gosh that's disappointing  that's so disappointing ah  what the heck happened to it alright so  right yep is iphone so what were some  surprises that we had that close up with  the 3x yeah the iphone being way better  a lot of the hdr seemed really good with  the samsung yeah like highlight roll-off  for all of the lenses the ultra wide the  main one the selfie selfie camera oh  it's shocking like if you like taking  selfies i think this is the best every  selfie was better yeah yeah if you like  shooting selfies and video i'm sorry  because the iphone blows away the video  quality and then the iphone's great for  portraits too for rear portraits it did  a really good job